bonjour à tous quelque chose me dit que
cette vidéo va faire plaisir à beaucoup
beaucoup de monde parce que ça fait très
longtemps qu'on réclame une vidéo sur
spinoza
ça fait plusieurs mois peut-être même
plusieurs années comme dit mais quand
est ce que tu vas nous faire une vidéo
sur spinoza
alors j'ai pris mon temps j'ai repoussé
et j'ai repoussé autant que possible
parce que spinoza c'est un monument de
la philosophie on ne s'attaque pas un
monument de cette envergure sans s'y
être un petit peu préparée et j'espère
que cette vidéo sera à la hauteur de vos
attentes
alors spinoza fait partie de ces auteurs
très difficile à aborder pour la simple
et bonne raison que son système
philosophique se veut un système de la
totalité pour le dire autrement
l'ambition
philosophique de spinoza c'est ni plus
ni moins que de nous expliquer dieu ou
la nature car pour lui c'est deux choses
se confondent dieu ou la nature c'est à
dire la totalité de ce qui est et vous
comprenez bien que traité de la totalité
dans une vidéo sur youtube
c'est forcément un petit peu délicat
donc je vais me prêter à l'exercice en
vous demandant par avance de
l'indulgence et pour parer cette
difficulté
cette vidéo se voudra une introduction à
la pensée de spinoza et non pas un
exposé exhaustif de sa philosophie
alors d'abord quelques éléments
biographiques parce que vous allez voir
spinoza c'était quand même un sacré
bonhomme spinoza philosophe du xviie
siècle juifs portugais émigrée aux pays
bas philosophe très controversé pour ses
positions en matière de religion
il faut savoir que spinoza a été
excommuniée par la communauté juive et
qu'il a même subi une tentative
d'assassinât
et d'ailleurs on notera que celui qui a
tenté de tuer espinosa a essayé de le
poignarder et spinoza à conserver le
manteau percée du poignard de son
assaillant jusqu'à la fin de sa vie ce
qui n'osa qui a publié son oeuvre
principale éthique en 1677 soit deux ans
après sa mort parce qu'il était
parfaitement conscient qu'une telle
oeuvre de son vivant aurait pu lui
valoir le but chez spinoza et l
philosophe qui n'hésitait pas à tailler
dans le vif et qui ne prenaient pas de
pincettes
alors on va voir concrètement en quoi
les positions philosophiques de spinoza
était pour l'époque totalement novatrice
voire révolutionnaire mais avant ça il
va falloir que je plante un peu le décor
alors ce qui n'osa est connu comme étant
le principal opposant de descartes à la
même époque opposant entre guillemets
parce qu'en réalité
spinoza ne rejette pas tout du corpus
cartésien mais il s'oppose à des cartes
sur un point absolument fondamental à
savoir que là-haut des cartes étaient 1
dualiste c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
établissent ait une séparation entre la
matière et l'esprit entre l'étendue et
la pensée pour spinoza remet les choses
n'étaient pas aussi nettement séparés
espinosa était une sorte de précurseur
de ce qu'on a appelé le monisme c'est à
dire l'idée qu'on ne pouvait pas
dissocier le corps et l'esprit
depuis platon cette séparation
ontologique entre le corps et l'esprit
était considéré comme une sorte
d'évidence une évidence qui épousait
très bien la vision chrétienne basée sur
un ici bas le monde de la matière et un
au delà le monde de l'esprit or pour
spinoza cette distinction n'a pas lieu
d'être car en réalité le corps et
l'esprit pour ceux qui n'osent ans ne
sont que deux attributs d'une substance
unique qu'il appelle dieu ou la nature
alors pour bien comprendre cette idée du
monisme spin aux armes
ben je vais recourir à quelques exemples
je vais prendre l'exemple du cannabis le
cannabis pour ceux qui connaissent ça
provoque une altération des capacités
psychiques une altération de ce qu'on
appelle l'état de conscience
si vous préférez quand on a fumé du
cannabis
on pense différemment on voit les choses
différemment mais en même temps
fumer du cannabis ça provoque aussi une
altération des capacités physiques
allez faire un combat de boxe allait
faire une séance de musculation
après avoir fumé un joint vous allez
voir que c'est pas la même limonade
ça devient très compliqué et à partir de
cet exemple on comprend assez bien
finalement que une altération psychique
s'accompagne inévitablement d'une
altération physique et qu'en réalité ces
deux dimensions la dimension spirituelle
et la dimension matérielle sont en
interaction
on peut pas les séparer on peut pas les
différencier comme s'il s'agissait de
deux choses indépendante
quand on a fumé du cannabis
on est mou et cette mollesse elle ne se
pose pas la question de savoir s'il ya
une différence entre le corps et
l'esprit
elle contamine les deux dimensions elle
contamine le corps et l'esprit de
manière indifférenciée
c'est ce qu'il aime
certains commentateurs à décrire la
pensée de spinoza comme un parallélisme
parallélisme du corps et de l'esprit de
l'étendue et de la pensée alors on
reparlera de cette distinction entre le
corps et l'esprit dans une prochaine
vidéo
mais comme je les dis la philosophie de
spinoza est une philosophie de la
totalité et pour cette première vidéo je
ne souhaite pas affronter directement
cette question je souhaiterais plutôt
l'aborder sous un autre angle
la plupart des philosophes offre de
nombreuses prises pour pénétrer leur
pensée et chez spinoza c'est plus
difficile
les prises sont plus rares mais j'ai
essayé d'en dégager une pour la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui je disais que chez spinoza
on ne retrouvait pas le dualisme
cartésien on ne retrouvait pas cette
séparation d'origine platonicienne entre
le corps et l'esprit
mais cette vision moniste a une
conséquence extrêmement concrètes
c'est la vision qu'avaient spinoza de la
liberté car pour spinoza mme laliberté
c'est une illusion alors avant d
qui et pourquoi la liberté selon spinoza
est une illusion
il faut déjà expliqué pourquoi chez
descartes la liberté est un présupposé
pour des cartes
l'homme possède un libre arbitre ans
c'est à dire une capacité à choisir le
libre arbitre chez descartes c'est ce
qu'il appelle le décret de l'âme
c'est à dire la capacité qu'a notre
volonté de se déterminer
indépendamment des influences
extérieures le libre arbitre
c'est l'indépendance de la volonté
vis-à-vis de la matière et le libre
arbitre
honda mentalement liés à cette
distinction entre le corps et l'esprit
parce que pour qu'il y ait liberté il
faut qu'il y ait possibilité pour
l'esprit de se déterminer
indépendamment du corps voilà pourquoi
le monisme de spinoza fait directement
obstacle à la notion de libre arbitre
pourquoi est-ce que le libre arbitre est
une illusion
et bien parce que l'homme parce qu il
fois un être physique et un être
spirituel
c'est à dire un être doué d'une
conscience est bien l'homme pense qu'il
est lui même l'auteur de ces actes
l'auteur de ces actes c'est à dire le
libre décideurs de sa manière d'agir
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose sur
quoi se fonde la plupart de nos sociétés
modernes
c'est l'idée que nous sommes maîtres de
notre corps et c'est ce qui induit la
notion de responsabilité
si nous ne possédions pas de libre
arbitre en la notion de responsabilité
n'existerait pas et donc la notion même
de justice au sens juridique du terme
n'aurait pas lieu d'être un tueur
pourrait très bien dire que c'est son
corps qui a agi et que sa volonté n'a
fait que suivre le mouvement de son
corps que donc il n'ya pas lieu de le
désigner comme coupable
si le libre arbitre n'existe pas ça
signifie que tout est justifiable et ça
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
révolutionnaire sans ce strict du terme
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose qui
remettrait complètement en question les
fondements mêmes de notre vie sociale
imaginez par exemple que celui qui vous
a trahis
celui qui vous a blessé celui qui vous a
menti pouvait se protéger derrière
l'abri du monisme spin aux yeux en
disant mais après tout je ne suis pas
responsable de ce que je fais je suis
entièrement déterminées donc je ne peux
pas me tenir coupable de ce que je fais
de préjudiciable pour toi donc la vision
spinoza n'est pas viable sur le plan
juridique aux politiques et pourtant met
le doigt sur
chose d'absolument fondamentale qui est
que tout bien considéré sommes nous
vraiment les hauteurs de nos actes
sommes nous vraiment les responsables de
ce que nous pensons et de ce que nous
faisons alors je dis de ce que nous
pensons et de ce que nous faisons parce
que comme j'ai déjà dit pour ceux qui
n'osent âme
il n'y a pas de différence fondamentale
entre la pensée et la matière spinoza
cette citation assez connu l'ordre et la
connexion des idées sont les mêmes que
l'ordre et la connexion des choses ce
qui signifie que nos actes ne sont que
la conséquence mécanique de nos idées de
même que nos idées ne sont que la
conséquence mécanique de nos actes
ces traits d
autant comme manière de voir les choses
parce que nous avons toujours tendance à
instaurer une antériorité entre la
pensée et l'action il était que l'action
serait déterminé par notre pensée ou au
contraire l'idée que notre pensée serait
déterminé par nos actions et pour
spinoza
c'est une mauvaise manière de voir les
choses c'est ne pas comprendre comment
fonctionne l'être humain et comment
fonctionne l'interaction entre le corps
et l'esprit
vous remarquerez que très souvent
lorsqu'on est placé dans des conditions
matérielles différentes bien on peut
avoir des opinions différentes et de la
même façon lorsque nos opinions évoluent
ça se répercute dans notre manière
d'agir et donc dans nos conditions
matérielles d'existence la vision peut
proposer des cartes c'est à dire l'idée
que l'être humain était guidé par son
libre arbitre
c'est en réalité la vision chrétienne
puisqu'on la trouve chez saint-augustin
qui disait que dieu avait doté l'homme
du libre arbitre et que par conséquent
vous pouvez pas attribué à dieu la
responsabilité du mal sur terre c'est
parce que l'homme possède le libre
arbitre qu'il a le choix de faire le
bien ou de faire le mal et c'est ce qui
faisait dire justement à des cartes que
l'être humain était le seul être en sûrs
terme qui était doué de ce libre arbitre
puisque les objets inanimés n'ont pas
d'âme
par définition donc ils n'ont pas de
volonté donc ils n'ont pas de libre
arbitre ans si je prends ce stylo qui
devant moi et que je le lance à travers
la pièce le stylo
pas le choix de sa trajectoire sa
trajectoire sera le résultat mécanique
de la direction et de la force avec
laquelle je l'aurais lancé n'a pas le
choix
le stylo de même pour des cartes
l'animal ne possède pas le libre arbitre
c'est d'ailleurs de là que vient sa
théorie de l'animal machine lorsque des
cartes disait que les animaux étaient
des machines évidemment il ne voulait
pas dire que les animaux étaient
composés de métal de ferraille ou je ne
sais quoi
pas du tout il voulait simplement dire
que les animaux obéit scène a quelque
chose qu'on appelle le l'instinct et
dans lequel la notion de volonté
n'intervient absolument pas tout
simplement parce que l'animal n'a pas
conscience de son instant l'homme serait
le seul à posséder le libre arbitre
parce qu'il a conscience de ceux qui
l'animent et la conscience de son désir
les animaux sont des machines parce
qu'ils agissent mécaniquement parce
qu'ils agissent sans conscience donc
sans volonté alors que les hommes
lorsqu'ils agissent sont poussés par une
conscience qui fait qu'on peut pas les
réduire à des objets inanimés à des
animaux c'est à dire qu'on peut pas les
réduire à leur dimension purement
physique et matérielle et dans une
certaine mesure c'est vrai l'homme n'est
pas obligé de se plier aux contraintes
extérieures il n'est pas obligé de se
plier aux influences multiples qu'il
reçoit l'as cette capacité de dire non
mais pour ce prix
armes ce n'est pas suffisant parce qu'en
réalité ce libre arbitre humain c'est
d'abord une illusion une illusion qui
vient du fait que l'homme n'a pas
conscience de ce qui est à l'origine de
ces désirs ou de ses pensées
l'homme a bien conscience qui peut
décider mais il n'a pas conscience de
l'historique des causes et des effets
qui l'amène à faire un certain choix à
tel moment dans telle situation
là encore je prendre un exemple
imaginons que vous êtes tranquillement
installé sur votre canapé en train de
regarder un film que tout à coup vous
avez envie d'aller dans votre
réfrigérateur pour prendre à yaourts
vous allez vous levez vous allez allez
chercher votre yaourt et puis vous allez
le manger en éprouvant un certain
plaisir en vous disant que c'est quand
même pas mal d'être un être humain parce
que on peut faire des choses qu'on
choisit espinosa
que à ce moment là vous oubliez que il
ya un certain nombre de raisons il ya un
certain nombre de facteurs qui vous ont
poussé à aller jusqu'à votre
réfrigérateur pour prendre à yaourts
toutes ces raisons on n'en a pas
conscience
et pourtant elles existent
ce que veut dire ce qui n'osa c'est que
certes nous avons pouvoir de choisir
mais nous n'avons pas le pouvoir de
choisir les raisons qui nous poussent à
choisir notre choix n'est en fait qu'un
choix de surface notre choix repose sur
le pur constat d'un désir d'une
affection
c'est à dire d'une envie d'une émotion
d'une passion et ses passions ce n'est
pas donc
et choisissons nous choisissons pas nos
sion une choisissons pas nos désirs ou
les subissions nous les subissons comme
le stylo subi l'impulsion que je vais
lui faire subir et qui va l'amener à
emprunter telle direction sans avoir la
possibilité de résister de ce point de
vue là pour spinoza
nous sommes prisonniers de ce qu'il
appelle le déterminisme le déterminisme
c'est l'idée que dans un monde physique
tout est soumis à la loi de la causalité
toute cause produit un effet qui devient
à son tour la cause d'un effet suivant
et ainsi de suite à l'infini qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on a envie d'un yaourt c'est
peut-être parce qu'on aura vu passer une
publicité pour un yaourt
quelques minutes avant le film et que
cette vision
or à pénétrer notre corps et notre
esprit un niveau infra convention est un
moment donné va faire naître cette envie
alors je prends cet exemple mais il y en
aurait une infinité d'autres
prenons l'exemple de l'élève de
terminale qui passe son bac et qui
décide de s'inscrire en fac de biologie
c'est un libre choix
il s'inscrit en fac de biologie comme il
aurait pu s'inscrire en fac de droit ou
en école de commerce mais il a choisi la
fac de biologie
c'est son choix mais qu'est ce qui a
motivé ce choix
qu'est ce qui a déterminé ce choix ça
peut être parce
que cet élève aura grandi dans une
famille de scientifiques qui lui auront
transmis le goût de la science le goût
de l'étude du corps humain et qui aura
fait que sans même s'en rendre compte
cette élève aura choisi la voie de la
biologie en étant fondamentalement
convaincu que c'est son choix et d'un
point de vue purement subjectif c'est
vrai d'un point de vue purement
subjectif ce choix ne pas être vécue
comme une obligation détermination
quelconque
ce choix sera vécu comme relevant d'une
libre décision
et pourtant ce choix aura des causes ce
choix sera le résultat d'un enchaînement
de causes et d'effets qu'ils auront
conduit à faire ce choix et tout ce
qu'on fait dans notre vie n'échappe pas
à cette règle de la causalité
parce que
l'être humain est un être physique
l'être humain est un être matériel et en
tant qu'être matériel il est soumis aux
lois de la matière ne peut pas s'y
soustraire
ne pas y échapper l'être humain en tant
qu'être physique et soumis aux lois
physiques
si vous décidez de vous jeter de votre
balcon pour essayer de vous envoler les
lois physiques vont vous rappeler à
l'ordre
elles vont vous dire tu ne peux pas n'a
pas cette liberté parce que la liberté
s'inscrit toujours à l'intérieur d'un
ensemble de contraintes physiques
ce serait comme de vouloir faire des
crêpes sans utiliser duff sans utiliser
de farine ça n'a aucun sens si tu veux
faire des crêpes
tu vas suivre une recette et si tu ne
suis pas la recette va pas pouvoir faire
des crêpes donc une réalisation dans le
monde physique présuppose l'obéissance
un certain nombre de règles
ça nous paraît évident mais ce n'est pas
évident ce n'est pas évident parce qu'au
quotidien
c'est très fréquent qu'on se comporte en
oubliant les lois fondamentales de la
matière prenez l'exemple des dominos qui
tombent en cascade
lorsqu'on pousse le premier on est bien
d'accord que lorsqu'on pousse le premier
domino la chute du dernier domino n'est
que la conséquence logique et mécanique
de la chute du premier
et pourtant dans la plupart de nos
agissements
nous ne faisons
la relation entre notre action et
l'effet final de notre action
la conséquence ultime de notre action
parce que nous sommes focalisés
uniquement sur la conséquence immédiate
de notre action un peu comme une mouche
qui s'obstinent à taper le carreau de la
fenêtre sans voir que la fenêtre est
ouverte
nous sommes dans cette
espèce d'enfermement mental intellectuel
qui nous empêche de voir l'enchaînement
des causes et des effets dans lequel
nous nous inscrivons et c'est cet
aveuglement
c'est un doublement à la causalité qui
fait dire à spinoza que le libre arbitre
est une illusion
il prend une métaphore extrêmement
simple à comprendre qui amène à fort de
la pierre que l'on lance sur le sol si
vous prenez une pierre et que vous la
lancez sur le sol
sa trajectoire sera défini par la
manière dont vous l'aurez lancé mais
imaginez que au moment où vous lâchez la
pierre sur le sol
celle ci se retrouve doués de conscience
qu'est ce qu'elle va se dire la pierre
vial va se dire qu'elle est elle même la
cause de son mouvement
c'est elle qui décide de là où elle va
pas se dire que sa trajectoire a été
déterminé par un élément extérieur et
bien pour spinoza remet
nous sommes dans la même situation que
cette pierre fut mission des mouvements
qui provient de l'extérieur et nous nous
plaisons à croire que nous sommes la
cause de ces mouvements pour spinoza
a le libre arbitre est une illusion
aussi longtemps que l'on pense être la
cause de nos agissements de nos
agissements et de nos pensées
parce que pour spinoza ces deux choses
sont indissociables alors évidemment la
question qui se pose après tout ça c'est
de se dire mais alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
est ce que ça veut dire l'homme n'est
finalement pas supérieur à une pierre ou
un animal qui l'est tout autant soumis
aux déterminations du monde extérieur et
qui n'a pas son mot à dire
est ce que ça veut dire que nous serions
finalement prisonnier d'une illusion
fondamentale d'un péché d'orgueil qui
nous ferait croire que nous sommes
libres libres de nos actions libre de
nos pensées mais qu'en réalité tout ça
ne serait que chimère et bien pas
totalement
et c'est là que vous
et apporter un correctif par rapport à
une interprétation commune de la pensée
de spinoza sur la question de la liberté
et du déterminisme il est de bon ton de
convoquer spinoza pour expliquer que
l'homme n'est pas plus libre que la
pierre qu'on lance que l'animal qui
obéit à son instinct il est de bon ton
de dix ans que l'idée de la liberté
n'est qu'une illusion philosophique qui
ne repose sur rien su rien d'autre que
l'ignorance des causes qui nous
déterminent ok alors il faut aller au
bout de la démarche et comprendre ce que
spinoza essayer de dire ce qui suppose
pour cela d'être allé au goût de la
lecture de l'éthique
je rappellerai ici que comme le disait
gilles deleuze
si le livre de spinoza s'appelle et hic
c'est qu'il repose sur l'idée que
l'homme a le choix parce que l'éthique
n'a de sens que pour des individus
possédant un pouvoir de détermination
sur eux mêmes ne le disais que si la
pensée de spinoza n'était qu'une
description de l'illusion du libre
arbitre
une description l'enchaînement des
causes et des effets le terme d'éthique
n'aurait pas lieu d'être
il aurait dû alors parler d'ontologie
c'est-à-dire de l'étude de l'être
l'étude de ce qui est pourtant spinoza
par le d'éthique c'est à dire qu'une
pensée dirigé vers l'action
l'éthique c'est la pensée tourné vers
l'action et si l'être
le pouvoir de déterminer son action
ignorez tout simplement pas lieu de
parler d'éthique
autrement dit pour spinoza la liberté
est possible la liberté existe alors la
question de savoir comment atteindre
cette liberté mais en fait spinoza nous
donne la réponse
il nous explique que l'être humain parce
qu'il possède une conscience est capable
de prendre conscience de ce qui le
déterminent il est capable de se rendre
compte qui subit des influences qui vont
orienter ses choix et ses actions et
cette conscience qu'ils appellent la
raison elle fait toute la différence
car c'est par la raison que l'homme
accède à la liberté
alors là il faut
petit peu les choses en détails parce
que c'est une notion qui n'est pas clair
pour tout le monde
la raison chez spinoza ce n'est pas
simplement la faculté de comprendre que
nous sommes déterminés c'est d'abord la
capacité de comprendre que nous sommes
déterminés mais déterminée par quoi
déterminée par des influences qui
agissent sur vous et qui agissent plus
particulièrement sur nos passions sur ce
que spinoza appelle nos affects et qu'on
traduirait aujourd'hui par le terme
d'émotions nos émotions et j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en parler dans ma vidéo sur
le stoïcisme à proprement parler nous ne
les maîtrisons pas elles nous arrivent
elles nous parviennent nous les
subissons
d'où le terme grec pathos pour parler
des passions les passions de l'âme
c'est à dire ce que notre âme subi
prenons quelques exemples on
l'inquiétude c'est à dire la non qui
es-tu de l'inquiétude
une passion l'inquiétude est un affect
l'attitude est quelque chose que nous
subissons lorsque nous nous trouvons
dans une situation d'incertitude mais
les à la peur notre conjoint qui devait
rentrer à 18h et qui n'est toujours pas
là à 19 heures alors il est possible que
ce conjoint et fait le choix de faire un
petit détour au bistrot pour partager un
un petit moment de détente avec ses amis
mais le fait est que si nous tentons de
le joindre sur son portable et qu'il ne
répond pas l'inquiétude pourra
apparaître à ce moment là et que nous
dit cette inquiétude elle ne nous dit
rien d'autre que l'ignorance de la
situation de notre conjoint et cette
ignorance cause en nous une peur la peur
qu'il soit arrivé quelque chose la peur
qu'il ait fait une mauvaise rencontre
la peur qu'ils soient en train de passer
un moment joyeux avec lesquin d'autres
que nous mais cette peur au fond et elle
rationnelle non cette peur n'est pas
rationnel dans la mesure où cette peur
n'apporte rien à la compréhension de la
situation
cette peur ne fait qu'apporter de la
souffrance à la souffrance elle ne
résout rien et là vous aurez reconnu un
petit fragment de stoïcisme chez spinoza
il y a du stock
si ce mot chez spinoza il ya du
stoïcisme parce qu'il y à l'idée que la
passion nous a servis et que la raison
nous libère et si vous êtes dans la
raison lorsque l'inquiétude vous
assaillent et bien l'inquiétude va
s'évanouir
elle va disparaître parce que
sion se dissout sous la force de la
raison qu'est ce qui fait que certaines
personnes arrivent à gérer avec
décontraction des tentes des situations
qui nous plongerait dans l'inquiétude
dans la peur ben c'est tout simplement
le travail en l2 la raison c'est à dire
de la conscience la conscience que notre
ressenti n'apportera aucune modification
à la situation n'apportera aucune
amélioration
et c'est lorsqu'on admet que la passion
ne change rien à la situation qu'on
entre dans la raison dans le temple de
la raison
la raison qui nous dit que nous n'avons
d' influence que sur ce qui dépend de
nous par exemple et si vous multipliez
cet exemple à tous les exemples
possibles de situations où l'émotion 30
dessus vous allez vous apercevoir que la
raison alain pouvoirs magiques
elle a le pouvoir de faire disparaître
l'émotion la faire disparaître le pathos
faire disparaître la souffrance et à ce
moment là nous dit spinoza vous allez
connaître la joie la joie qui n'est pas
une émotion la joie thiais une manière
d'être et qui consiste dans la
compréhension rationnelle de se quitter
parce que dès lors que vous êtes animé
par la joie autrement dit dès lors que
vous êtes animé par la raison
la raison qui fait s'évanouir toute
passion toute affection bien ce moment
là tout ce que vous allez faire vous
allez le faire de manière libre je sais
quelque chose qui est difficile à
conceptualiser parce que c'est d'abord
quelque chose qui s'expérimente mais
l'action dans la joie c'est l'action
dans la conscience que ce qui est ne
peut être que ce type est et dans cette
l'action se produit quelque chose
d'absolument phénoménal qui est la joie
intense de l'être la joie intense de ce
qui est et la pleine conscience de notre
pouvoir notre pouvoir d'agir contre
pouvoir de penser notre pouvoir d'être
la liberté existe chez spinoza
parce que la liberté n'est pas un
pouvoir d'indétermination ce n'est pas
le pouvoir de s'extraire des
déterminations physique c'est le pouvoir
de comprendre que tout est déterminé et
que partant de là il est possible de
comprendre tout ce qui est et agir en
comprenant tout ce qui est c'est agir
librement ses draps
sur quoi il faut insister la liberté
chez spinoza est liée à la raison c'est
à dire au pouvoir de compréhension de ce
guide et vous n'êtes pas libre de faire
en sorte que deux plus deux égale 5
vous n'êtes pas libre vous êtes au bout
j'ai de l'accepter mais est ce que cet
accès
sion est douloureuse pour vous est ce
que cette acceptation est un sacrifice
est ce qu elle est coûteuse pour vous
non elle n'est pas coûteuse
tout simplement parce qu'elle n'a -
drian en rien ce que vous êtes
parce qu'elles ne touchent pas votre
orgueil votre estime de vous même elle
n'atteint pas vos passions elle
n'atteint pas vos affection vous êtes
donc d'accord pour dire qu accepter que
deux plus deux égale 4
c'est finalement se donner plus de
liberté que de croire que de + 2 égale 5
parce que si vous croyez que de + 2
égale 5 ha d'une manière ou d'une autre
ça va vous poser problème dans la vie
vous n'êtes pas libre de faire en sorte
que le théorème de pythagore ne sont pas
valables
vous n'êtes pas libre de faire en sorte
que la gravité disparaissent vous
composer avec vous l'acceptez la gravité
comme vous accepter l'idée de la mort
vous acceptez qu'un jour ou l'autre vous
allez passer l'armé à gauche et que
c'est dans l'ordre des choses dans
l'ordre et la connexion des choses
pourtant c'est une idée que vous pouvez
rejetée mais qu'est ce qu'ils rejettent
cette idée là encore c'est l'ego c'est
l'orgueil
c'est la peur ce sont des passions la
raison consisterait à accepter l'idée de
la mort non pas la souhaitait non pas à
vouloir la précipiter mais à l'accepter
comme données rationnelle du monde
physique
et si vous êtes
et cette idée au plus profond dans si
vous l'intérioriser à tel point que
cette idée ne cause plus en vous de peur
bien ce moment là vous n'êtes plus
asservi à la peur de la mort vous n'êtes
plus asservi à tout ce qui découle de la
peur de la mort
la raison est libératrice la raison vous
libère de vos peurs elle vous libère de
vos passions elle vous libère de tout ce
qui vous fait refuser le réel parce
qu'on est quand même très fort pour
refuser ce qui est on est très fort pour
trouver des responsables ou des
coupables à notre propre incapacité à
accepter ce qui est être spinosi à
commettre stoïciens ne pas être
fataliste ce n'est pas renoncer
ce n'est pas se résigner c'est
comprendre que ce qui est a des raisons
d'être à des causes d'être et qu'on peut
pas s'opposer aux causes ne pas
s'opposer à ce qui régit notre monde
physique
en revanche on peut comprendre ce qui
régit notre monde physique et comprendre
qui signifie étymologiquement à françois
comprendre c'est accepter comprendre
c'est enregistré
et lorsqu'on comprend quelque chose on
s'allège ont franchi un pas vers la
liberté
l'homme libre et celui qui par un
travail de la raison n'est plus soumis à
ses passions libre et l'homme qu'il agit
conformément à la raison car en
comprenant la série des causes et des
effets l'homme peut s'extraire de ses
passions
il peut s'extraire de ce que les lois de
la matière du fonds subie l'an car si
vous
qui est qu'un être physique le moindre
événement extérieur pourrait produire
sur vous une passion vous n'avez pas
décidé d'éprouver le stylo ne peut pas
empêcher la trajectoire que je lui fait
subir en revanche vous qui m'écoutent et
vous avez le pouvoir d'art se voir les
passions du monde extérieur ne pas
recevoir les émotions liées à ce qui
vous arrive de ne pas être asservi par
vaux pas su vous allez pouvoir les
comprendre de les mettre à distance de
les poser à plat devant vous et de
comprendre le principe de leur formation
le processus par lequel ses passions son
entrée en vous vous avez ce pouvoir et
vous allez constater lorsque vous
comprenez ce processus parce que vous
comprenez comment est née l'émotion que
vous ressentez actuellement comment
s'est formé l'inquiétude
quelle est la cause de cette peur qui
vous accompagnent qui vous alourdi de
comprendre que tout ça n'est qu'un
enchaînement de causes et d'effets que
vous n'êtes pas obligé de subir comme si
vous n'étiez que des réceptacles vous
avez un pouvoir c'est le pouvoir de la
raison et ne tient qu'à vous de
l'exercer je vous remercie
[Musique]